Well, last week we began this kind of new mini series as we're kind of moving into this
second year of Trinity Fellowship in Romans 15, which we just called this one voice,
glorifying God through our worship, welcome, and witness. So last week we were looking at what
it means to glorify God through our worship. This morning it's glorifying God through our
welcome and then next week through our witness. And that's basically coming from,
we're kind of camping out around verses five to seven. But there in verse six you see this,
it's Paul's earnest desire that the church together would with one voice glorify the God and Father of
our Lord Jesus Christ. And so really that is the purpose of the church, to glorify God. We do that
through our worship of God and through our welcome of one another and our witness to the world
around us. So we're looking at that second one, glorifying God through our welcome of one another
in the life of the church. Well, when we, as when Julie and I and a couple of the kids lived in
Burkina Faso, West Africa, one of the things that we came away that just kept ringing in our ears
as we came back, that summarized what we learned from folks there, was a phrase called
Vuzette en Vite. Vuzette en Vite. So it's a French speaking country as the official language. And so I
would, you go to somebody's house and then have food out for you, rice and some kind of sauce.
And once the food had been brought out, they would say, Vuzette en Vite, you are invited.
But it wasn't just a situation like that. You would go to an ATM in the city and there'd
be a security guard sitting outside having his lunch. And as you'd walk up, it had been rude
for him to not say this. He looked up and he'd say, Vuzette en Vite, you're invited.
We were at a little cafe one time and somebody else's food arrived outside this cafe before ours
arrived. We were sitting there about waiting our food and the guy looked over across the way, he said,
Vuzette en Vite. So there was a kind of a mindset that was there that what I have is not
just for me, it's for the community around me. And that was kind of reflected in that kind
of continual offer of food that was before you. So it was courteous, but it was also real. If we
just said, okay, we're invited, we're going to come and we're going to share this meal together,
they'd been very happy. And when we were working with the local church there, the particular
local church, it was they met together in a very similar way. And I was tempted to do
this this morning. They would meet together in the rounds, almost like you'd meet around a meal.
And there was an open invitation. And so they would meet in the round, but there
would always be a space for you to be able to get into that circle that was the church.
This kind of open invitation to come and see as we're feasting together
on what the Lord has provided for us. And coming to know this community that he is building,
we're inviting others into that, welcoming one another. So we have this invitation before us,
similarly in Romans 15, seven, let's read it again. Therefore, welcome one another,
as Christ has welcomed you for the glory of God. So what does it mean to be a welcoming church?
Well, the word welcome here just means to accept, but more literally, it means to take to oneself,
to bring somebody close to you, like you have something to say to somebody, you're like,
hey, come over here, and you're walking alongside them, and you're talking to them. That word
is, is you're welcome them drawing them to yourself. There's also a word that was used
to describe showing hospitality to somebody. So that taking to oneself is just like having
somebody over for a meal and saying, well, this is how we should treat one another in the church.
Now, this may sound simple, but the closer you look, the more you realize this isn't
necessarily the case. You know, whether it's having, for example, good intentions to be
hospitable, you know, hey, we should, we should have you around sometime. We should meet
up sometime, but not actually following through with that kind of just nice thing that we tend to
say here in the South, hey, we should meet up sometime or actually attempting it and trying
to be a hospitable person and then discovering how hard it can actually be to spend time in
close proximity with people. Welcoming one another can be challenging. Well, in Romans 14 and 15,
we see that the church in Rome was facing a challenge when it came to this, their, their
lives together and things were starting to get prickly. It was a mix of Jewish and Gentile believers
and so there were particular questions regarding what foods were acceptable to eat when they were
gathered together. You know, should they be observing the kind of dietary laws or not?
What should they do about holy days? Should, what, what ones should they observe or not
observe and how does that affect when they meet together or where they meet? But the biggest issue
was not who was right, who was wrong about what food should or should not be brought to the potluck.
The issue was, or the issue being addressed by Paul was how they were disagreeing with one another,
the way they were going about this disagreement, how they're treating one another over these things.
So if you go back to chapter 14 and verse one, you see that there's not just this
disagreement, there's this kind of dispute that's happening. There's a kind of an argumentative
spirit that's creeping into the life of the church. Not only that, you go on to verse three,
there's, there's even a tendency towards even moving into despising one another once you've
had these disagreements they've lingered for a little while. So these disagreements like,
let's remember, these aren't over core doctrines like what is the gospel? Did Jesus really rise
again from the dead? They're not over like core things about like what does it mean to follow
Christ? What is plain before us in Scripture? These were over kind of peripheral things.
And yet they were really divided over them it seems. You know we live in a society that is
increasingly divided and what a testimony and witness it could be if the church was united
together. But so often the division that you see reflected in society is no different to what you
see in the life of the church in America more broadly. But even if you go into a local church
and that's something we can do something about, are we united? Are we welcoming one another as we
have been welcomed by Christ? You see this unity is something that's a danger that every church
faces and don't think the church plants are the exception. If anything there's a greater
intensity that comes to church planting because it's all hands on deck and there's a lot to do.
But you know the church is made up of all different personalities and preferences and age
and ethnicities and cultures and worship style preferences and political opinions and the list
could go on and on. And sometimes the division can take the form of like loudly opposing one
another. Sometimes it can just take the form of I think this is probably more often just
keeping our distance from one another. Just letting it cool and perhaps finding you know some other place
it's a bit closer to where we might be at where there's more folks that are just like us whatever
that is for you. We can lean towards division rather than unity that is ours in Jesus. See God
calls us to something far greater here. He calls us to worship Him with one voice. Remember
that's that picture of unity that kind of harmonizing together for the glory of God as our
lives are brought together in Christ. And we do that by welcoming one another as we have been
welcomed by Christ. So how do we do that? Two big things we're going to look at. One is we are we
need to realize that we are a welcomed people. And once we know what it means to be a welcomed
people we're then transformed to be a welcoming people. All right so if we're going to know
what it means to be a welcoming people we must first know what it is to be a welcomed
people to have been welcomed by Christ. You see the reason we seek to welcome others is because
we were first welcomed by Jesus. So we need to understand what it is to understand and
understand that welcome and what it is to experience it. All right so let's look at the
ministry of Jesus. I mean so Jesus was known for how he welcomed people. So what was his
reputation? So Luke chapter 7 verse 34 for example he was known as a friend of tax
collectors and sinners. This is an insult hurled at Jesus' direction because of all the people
he's eating with. He's spending time with all the wrong sorts of people and
welcoming them, taking them into himself. But he made it clear in John chapter 6 and verse 37
whoever comes to me I will never cast out. I won't turn them away if they're coming to me.
This was God's plan all along. That's what we see in Romans 15. We saw a little bit of
this last week as the whole kind of storyline of Scripture is put before us. In verse 8 you see
Jesus came to fulfill the covenant promises that he made to the people of Israel. What are some of
those promises? Well Micah 7 for example he promised to forgive their sins. He says you will cast all
our sins into the depths of the sea. This is what Scripture says. You will show faithfulness
to Jacob instead fast love to Abraham as you have sworn to our fathers from the days of old.
Alright so how is God going to forgive the sins of his people through the coming of Christ?
Jesus accomplished it through what? Verse 8? Becoming a servant. Alright so this is what Jesus was
saying in Mark chapter 10 and verse 45. The Son of man came not to be served but to serve.
How did he serve? Lots of ways but the biggest way he served was by laying down his life as a ransom
for many. Right so through becoming a servant laying down his life on the cross that results in
the forgiveness of sins. But Jesus didn't just lay down his life so that the people of Israel
would be forgiven for their sins. Jesus died for the world. He didn't just come for
Jews who would come to him. He came for Gentiles who would put their faith in him as well.
Alright so this was promised all the way through. This is what you see like in verse 9. Jesus came
in order that the Gentiles might glorify God for his mercy. And Paul then quotes all those
verses from the Old Testament that show that it's been God's plan all along to welcome people from
all over the world. The Gentiles are the nations of the world. His plan from the beginning was to
welcome people from every tribe, tongue, and nation to himself. His plan was that the Gentiles
might also glorify God for his mercy. To create this church made up of people from all nations
who are giving glory to God for the mercy they've come to know in Jesus. Put it in the
language of welcome. We were estranged but Jesus died for us that he might welcome us home to himself.
We had chosen to leave him to go our own way to run away from home if you will. But Jesus took
our judgment that we might be forgiven. He was exiled that we might be welcomed home.
He draws us back to himself. There's a story that always comes to my mind when I think
about the welcome we've been shown in Jesus. And there's been country songs written about it and old
readers digest stories that were in my grandmother's house that they were there. And I'm sure one or two
of the details are even true when it comes to the story. But it's a story of a man who was,
had been in prison for years, done something awful. And he eventually got to the place after years
in prison where he was really sorry for what he'd done and it just felt awful and tried to
write to his family and he told them, look I'm about to be released and I'm really sorry for what
I did to you for being locked away for all this time and how irresponsible it was and just wrote
this beautiful apology. And he said in it, he said, well I'm about to, I'm going to get out in
such and such a day and I'm going to get a bus and it's going to go right by where our house
is. He says, if you would forgive me and welcome me back to yourself, if you would just tie
a yellow ribbon around the tree out in our front yard and have that there, then I'll know that I'm
welcome, you know, to come and knock on the door. And I would totally understand if you would not
forgive me. So if that's the case, then just don't put anything out and I'll just keep driving by
and you don't have to ever hear from me again. The story goes the bus turns the corner as they
get to that house and outside the house just glowing yellow. It's not just a ribbon, the
whole tree is covered. There's yellow sheets kind of out on the front of the, on the front of the
lawn just everywhere is covered in bright yellow. And so that picture just lives rent free in my
mind because I think, you know, that kind of welcome, you know, that's there, you know, as the
wife comes out with the kids and is welcoming this husband back into her life. That's a dim
reflection of the welcome that we have received in Jesus when we think about how he has sinned
against God and how we've turned away from all that we've done. The fact that if we come to
him in repentance and faith, he's ready to welcome us home to himself not because of what we've done,
but because of what he has done for us. So the question though is not do you understand the
welcome that is offered to us in Jesus, but have you personally experienced this? So when Paul is
writing to the church here, he's talking to them about, he's reminding them of the welcome they
have already received in Jesus. So have you received this welcome? And also are you living
in light of this welcome? Because those who are living in light of this welcome
are praising God for what he has done for them in Christ. They're living from a position of
praise, but they're also welcoming others because of this welcome they've received in Jesus. It
changes the way you view other people too. All right, so let's move into that now. All
right, so if we understand and we've experienced the welcome of God in Christ,
that transforms us so that we might welcome others in a Christ-like way.
There's one pastor and author that I've really benefited from. I'd recommend to
read him. He's a guy called Ray Ortland. He's come across him before. He's done some good
podcasts as well that are out there, but he talks about how a church that is centered on the
gospel will be a church that's characterized by two things. One is gospel doctrine and the other is
gospel culture. And he says that, like the thing is you can you can unsay with your culture in a church
what you've actually said in your doctrine. So you can you can be preaching and teaching the
right things just kind of right down the line, faithful to scripture, and your church culture
not reflect that in any way. And people can't hear the truth that you're saying because your
lives together are not reflecting that. So it's important for us to get into the specifics of
the gospel, yes, but also to get into the specifics of how should that shape us individually, but also
in our lives together. Well here we see, here's how the gospel shapes us. The Christ who welcomed
sinners like us to himself wants us to be transformed into his likeness to the degree
that we welcome others to him or to us as well. And so Christ welcomes sinners, people who don't
have it all together and we stand ready to do the same. So the welcome of Christ is seen and how we
welcome one another. All right, so let's be less pushing the specifics of that. I'll just mention
three. One of the ways it affects us for thinking well how do I welcome others as Christ
has welcomed me. It affects who we welcome. That's one thing. So for following Jesus that will be seen
in who we choose to spend our time with, who we love. The general rule of thumb will be if he
receives them, then I'll receive them as well. I'm ready to do that. Any friend of Jesus is a
friend of mine. So for following him that will be reflected in having a relationship with a wide
array of people. You know the color palette that Jesus is painting from so to speak has lots of
different colors on it. And the beauty of the gospel is really brought through when we care for people
that we wouldn't naturally be drawn to. The fact is like anybody can hang out with people they
have an affinity with. People they enjoy. Like I've had many wonderful like Muslim friends or
atheist friends. They all do that. Like they hang out with people that they would naturally hang out
with. Don't think that Christians don't do the same thing. You know where we just want to spend time
with people who we would hang out with anyway whether or not we shared that same faith.
We don't always get this right. I don't always get this right. It's good to know that
Paul didn't always get this right and Peter didn't always get this right either. Peter
specifically. Do you remember what happened in Galatians? Was it one and two? It was one of the
biggest, tensest moments in the New Testament. Peter had been spending time with Paul and eating with
Gentile believers as well as Jewish believers. They were enjoying these meals together.
Peter was Jewish. And then when some of the Jewish leaders came up to observe what was
happening all of a sudden Peter changed his act completely around and he would not eat with a
Gentile believers anymore. He was only eating with the Jewish believers. So how did Paul address that?
This kind of two-facedness. Like he's willing to do it one second but when he's seen by the wrong
people not want to do it another second. Here's what he said. Galatians 2 and verse 14. Paul said
that what he was doing was not right because it was not in step with the gospel. The way he
was treating others was not the way he had been treated by Christ or the way that Christ had
treated them or welcomed them. So he was to walk in step with the gospel and welcoming a diverse
group of people. And this isn't the only way to do it but this is why in our home groups we try
to for them to be as diverse as possible and not just based around affinity. Now there's
nothing wrong with hanging out with people who enjoy doing similar things. But we're really
trying to lean in that direction of like there's a diverse family of God and we want to see that
reflected not just in kind of gathering on Sundays but when we're you know sharing our lives
together. We need that kind of we need to answer knuckles in the faith, cousins in the faith
and all the rest. All right it affects who we welcome it also affects how we welcome, how we
welcome. There's lots of practical details we could get into when it comes to what we do with
our time or our homes or that sort of thing but there's something underneath all of that
that is even more important. Okay here's how Christ changes how we welcome one another. First of all
he gives us a new posture, a new posture. See what you might call gospel hospitality is first of all
about our posture towards the Lord and towards one another. Romans 14-15 we see that the church is
being called to walk in love. So what Paul says in Romans 15-7 is just another way of saying that
like there to walk in love and how they welcome one another. So we love others and that love will be
seen in us taking the initiative and seeking opportunities to draw them in to relationship,
authentic relationships, caring relationships within the life of the church. So Jesus loved us,
he came to where we were and he was really ready and willing to do what was necessary to welcome
us even at a cost to himself and that should shape us as well. We should have a posture that says
I'm willing to do whatever is necessary to serve you. Another thing about the posture here is a
posture of if we love others we're seeking their good. We're not just making sacrifices,
we're making sacrifices for the good of others. So Romans 15 we read in verse 2,
let us each please his neighbor for his good to build him up. So that's the aim here we're seeking to
build one another up that we might grow together in Christ's likeness. So that's the aim here. So
we're drawn together in relationships not just so that we have a caring community but so that we
have a Christ-like community as we're serving one another in his name. All right so it shapes
our posture, we want to be together, we want to help one another out, we want to receive that as well
but it also shapes our practices. So gospel hospitality portrays the self-giving love
of Christ that's what welcoming is. So Jesus self-giving love for the good of others
should be seen. Let's put it this way in the degree to which we welcome one another.
Let me go back to Ray Orland again because he's really helpful in this. He says one way to see
that kind of degree thing here is to when it comes to welcome one another as Christ has welcomed you
when it says as Christ has welcomed you it doesn't, what do you think, well how has Christ
welcomed me? Well it doesn't kind of then work to put something else in the place of welcome
one another because so for example he says it's great to say hi to one another as you're
walking in to church on Sundays but you can't really say say hi to one another as Christ has
said hi to you for the glory of God. There's not a weightiness to that, there's so much more than
just saying hey how you doing? There's a closer relationship there, there's a depth of sacrifice
that is there in this welcome. Should reflect the cross. So a welcoming church isn't a church
that's just ready to welcome people into their services and kind of smile and hand them a worship
guide that we should do that. A welcoming church is a church that stands ready to welcome people
into our very lives where we are, where we live. You see Jesus died not only that we might be
forgiven but that we might be reconciled to God. So it's not just about us being let off the
hook when it comes to our relationship with God like you're forgiven now just leave me alone.
God reconciles us to himself. Same thing in our relationships with each other. We should be forgiving
yes forgiving one another. It's not I'll forgive you just keep your distance from me please.
It's also a culture of reconciliation. I forgive you and I welcome you into my life. I draw you near.
These believers in Rome had some issues to work on here when it came to these dietary
restrictions and what days to do it on and not but let's commend them for a second.
If they were trying to figure out what food can we eat or not eat I'm mad at this person for
bringing that over. Let's commend them for this. They were sharing meals together. Let's not overlook
that small thing. They were spending time with one another in table fellowship and that is kind of
what created some of these thorny issues because they were together. So let's commend them for that.
Let's move in that direction so that we have to be reminded of why we are here doing that sort of
thing. It's not just the example here we have in the church in Rome. We've got some clear
commands in scripture to show hospitality to one another. I mean just go back to Romans 12
in verse 13 it says to every believer. Then talk about if you are gifted in this way if you
are so inclined it says to every believer seek to show hospitality. The New Testament makes it clear
that New Testament believers these early Christians met with each other in each other's homes they
shared meals together they spent their lives together and then they were repeatedly commanded
to show hospitality. Now hospitality don't hear that think oh well that means you pull out all
the best plates and you we have these cultural ideas of what hospitality is but that's not what
we're talking about in scripture. Hospitality is simply embodying the loving welcome of Christ
in practical terms. Let's put it like let me say it this way if we're not sure how to get started
consider just inviting somebody into wherever you're at whether it's your home or you're
going out to eat somewhere or what going on a walk just invite somebody into the everyday
rhythms of what you do just don't do it alone do it with somebody else you're going to watch the game
invite somebody into that you know. So we're created to live life together.
So this is an entertaining that word is sometimes used as a synonym for hospitality it's not
entertaining and it's not trying to impress remember this is about his glory pointing others to Jesus
not the glory of how how nice my house is or how clean it is or how the food was or anything like
that it's inviting people to know the love of Jesus in an authentic relationship with another
brother or sister in Christ. So we might say well who who am I going to do that with
when am I going to do that I'm not be a good one I'm not going to give you the answer to that but
lastly it gives us a new posture a new posture so we got or not a new posture we've already
covered this we've got the posture that's practice we'll give you another p it gives us a new power
we think about welcome the way perceived in Jesus so Julia teaches art at an elementary school
and she's shown me some of the stuff that she's done with some of the students but she'll like
paint like an example of what they're aiming to paint and then she'll give them the tools to paint it
and then she kind of lets them you know have a go like try to do the painting but she doesn't
then go and have a coffee and leave the classroom and then just I'd see what the result is she
comes alongside the children as they're painting to kind of help them make improvements along
the way that's part of teaching so that's what we have here we like this is the example this
look at Jesus that's what it means to love and welcome one another and here's what you need to do it
all right she's been brought into the life of the church but God by his spirit that comes alongside
us actually within us and he empowers us to do the very thing he's calling us to do
the same grace that welcomed us empowers us to welcome others in the same way the very spirit
of Christ enables us to welcome each other in a christlike way so where do we see that go back to
verse five may the god of endurance and encouragement we need this we're going to persevere in what we're
talking about but notice this word may that god grant you to live in such harmony with one another
so a church is living together in that kind of loving harmony
is one where God's grace is being poured out God is giving that to his church
so Christ doesn't receive us because we're good at welcoming one another and he doesn't reject us when
we're failing to do that no he loves us and he wants to help us to grow in this so much so
he is the one who gives the growth in this area and we're looking to him not ourselves even if we
feel like we've failed in this area we're saying we look to him and he doesn't say well you've really
blown it he says okay well I've welcomed you and I'll help you to take steps in that direction
first Thessalonians chapter 2 verses 12 and 13 says it in this way says may the lord make you to
increase in a bound in love for one another and for all we want to increase in this area and the
lord's the one who does it he gives what he calls us to so sure we should want to strive in this
area to to grow in this area and it involves effort sure but it is ultimately a gift and that's why
all the glory goes to God you know sometimes we have might hesitate to welcome others because we
don't want to be rejected or sound stupid or whatever in conversation or we might welcome one another
because we think we'll do a good job we want to impress them with it but the gospel gives us
a better mode and that's the glory of God welcome one another to the glory of God do you want to see
the glory of God I know I do honestly you know I'd love to maybe go to some national parks or something
and see you know it's a beautiful sunrise among these places God says here like you want to see
my glory there's a place that I want to reveal the brightness of my glory the the beauty of my
majesty in this world and it's greater than what you see out in creation he wants to reveal his glory
in the church he wants us to know his presence presence here where is he going to put it that
glory on display in our relationships with each other we don't always conceptualize of our
relationships in that way is the glory of God revealed in our relationships with one another I hope so
you know I love the simplicity of how we're approaching church life together
relationally but you know I love some good stained glass windows as well I don't think we put any here
I might put an requested city or something but for those of you who grew up redeemer before you'll
know there's some like big stained glass windows in the building they're in I would get distracted
when I was there looking up at them the pictures that are there you've got all these different
colors these these different shards of glass put together and you'd have that kind of light shining
through and for me that's just a that's an image of God's glory shining through the church
you know church has lots of different sorts of people in it we're all broken it might be tempting
to look at all the shards of glass so to speak but they will want a mess but the Lord takes all
of that puts all of our lives together the light of his glory shines through and this image is eliminated
what image is it it's the image of his son it's the brightness of his glory revealed in Jesus
who's that envy today let's pray
I would thank you that you invite us into the life of your church
the Lord we know that that's first of all because you've invited us to know life with you
in and through Jesus and Lord I pray that Lord as we come to your table here in just a moment Lord
I pray though in our hearts first of all that we would be approaching you Lord that we would be
receiving the welcome that you have given us in Jesus who died for our sins and rose again
we would experience this loving relationship with you the triune God who's welcomed us to himself
and Lord I pray well thank you for all my brothers and sisters here Lord I pray that you
would help us to grow in our love for one another I'm gonna pray that the love of Jesus would be
reflected in ever-increasing ways in our relationships one with another Lord I pray that as that happens
or that you keep us from just looking inwardly Lord I pray that you'd help us to be looking
outwardly as well that we would ready to receive others in that because it's all for your glory
in Jesus name